- [Kelly] Tracy was born
and raised in New York
one of the greatest cities in the world.
I haven't had a chance to
explore much this week.
So I've asked Tracy to
give me a little tour.
This is Tracy Morgan's oral
history of New York city.
[Audience Cheering]
- Tracy Morgans oral history of New York.
[Laughing]
- [ Kelly ] Okay, I'm
going to be singing that
in my sleep tonight.
What I'll do is name a location
in New York and Tracey will
tell us his personal history
behind it. Here we go.
Are you ready?
- [Tracey] Ready?
- [Kelly] Okay. The Bronx zoo.
- [Tracey] I got lost to
the Bronx zoo when I was
about 11 years old.
I got lost.
My, I went with the camp
and my guardian's name was Spencer.
And he got
we got in the zoo and he
told us not to feed none
none of the animals.
What did little Tracy do?
I started throwing food at the chimpanzee.
He hit me with a switch on my
back and I ran and I was lost.
But then they found me about
two, three hours later.
- [Kelly] Okay, in your
defense he hit you with
switch on your back.
- [Tracey] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I'd of left too.
Okay, the old Yankee Stadium.
- [Tracey] I met my first wife
Sabina, Morgan at gate four.
Cause I worked at gate
four, scalping tickets.
I scalped tickets and I
sold soap in their hands.
And I was sold pretzels.
(audience claps)
I sold everything.
At gate four
And also that's where I honed
in on my sense of humor.
That's what I homed in on
my craft selling souvenirs.
But I still, I overcharged Lauren Michaels
about fourteen dollars.
Lauren I owe you fourteen
dollars, for little bags.
- [Kelly] Dewitt Clinton high school
- [Tracey] Dewitt Clinton
high school is where
I graduated from.
I dropped out in 87
because my dad died of aids
but they gave me an honorary
diploma, when I was on my first
year on Saturday night live.
So Dewitt Clinton, DWC.
- [Kelly] Wow
- [Tracey] I love you Dewitt Clinton
and plus it's very prominent high school.
A lot of people come from DWC.
- [Kelly] How, how old were
you when that happened?
- [Tracey] When my dad died?
I was nineteen
I got left back in the first grade.
My oldest brothers was born
with cerebral palsy so.
I was kept out of school a lot.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, that's a lot.
- [Tracey] Yeah, and I
overcame a lot of that stuff
to be who I am.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Tracey] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Well, I heard
you lost something there.
- [Tracey] I lost my virginity there.
- [Tracey] In the staircase
with two sisters
two twins.
I love y'all.
- [Kelly] He meant it then
and he still means it now.
- [Tracey] Oh yeah, I was a dynamo.
I was on the football team
and the track team too.
I had a lot of energy.
{audience claps]
- [Tracey] Lot of energy brother.
- [Kelly] Earmuffs Maven, earmuffs.
- [Tracey] I'm gifted.
- [Kelly] Wait, the Apollo theater.
- [Tracey] Oh the Apollo
theater is where I
brought a bomb there at one time.
When I first started,
I ripped it the first week, I ripped it.
Then I went back to the second
week and the Apollo ground
got a way of letting you know
don't bring that Nickelodeon here.
So, I brought it. They all like this.
(gasps) He cruised.
So I looked over to the side
and the sound man was screwing
the hook together
because he was going to get me.
So I ran off the stage and
knocked the lucky log over.
- [Kelly] Oh, the lucky, I've..
- [Tracey] And they
banned me for two years.
- [Kelly] I was going to say you did what!
I've done that, on that log.
- [Tracey] No, I did that,
I knocked it over you
ain't getting me.
You ain't getting me.
I'm funny.
(audience laughs)
- [Tracey] Okay, wait
best in New York, people have
brought me pizza on the show
Okay, so like..
- [Tracey] I can tell you what,
I don't eat anybody pizza.
Okay. I went to LA eat some
pizza, and I spit that out.
(audience laugh)
Gone in the water, man.
The bagels and the pizza,
I can't dude, I can't do.
I can't do that.
(audience cheers)
New York City baby.
- [Kelly] Wait but what..
- [Tracey] Two thirty first street Sammy's
Sammy's on two thirty first
street in Broadway in the Bronx.
Best pizza ever.
- [Kelly] I've had that pizza, somebody.
- [Tracey] Sammy's, yeah?
- [Kelly] Somebody got
me Sammy's, I think it..
- [Tracey] But it's all in the sauce
because a lot of people to be getting
away with stuff where it's
just cheese and bread.
Nah, the sauce is where the money is.
The sauce is good.
You good?
(audience claps and laughs)
I'm telling you, kay swears,
the sauces, check out
the sauce.
- [Kelly] I love that my
name slightly changes.
- [Tracey] I don't eat that [Inaudible]
I'll eat good pizza.
He'll cut some pieces,
everybody don't cut my hair.
(laughing)
I got to wear this.
I'm not going to Kelly Clarkson like that.
I'm not doing that.
I got a bald patch right
here, I'm not doing that.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] And that
is Tracy Morgan's oral
history of New York.
(audience cheers and claps)
- [Tracey] Also, she was born in Cornell.
She was born in New York City.
So she's a Manhattan girl.
- [Kelly] Ahhh
- [Tracey] Eight years go.
And I was standing right there.
I'm the one that cut the umbilical
cord. And I pulled it out
- [Kelly] Ohh, you.
- [Tracey] I put on her mother.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Tracey] And she was crying.
They wiped off.
They, and they gave it to me.
She started crying, and I said Maven.
And she stopped crying and
looked at me and went back to
sleep.
(audience swoons)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Tracey] That's the
connection right there.
- [Kelly] Y'all are adorable.
- [Tracey] That's my connection.
- [Kelly] That's a great thing.
- [Tracey] She looked like me?
- [Kelly] Y'all look beautiful
both of you.
- [Tracey] She look like me?
She better.
- [Kelly] Okay
(audience laughs)
Y'all don't know how man
feel when some people say
they look just like you.
Well they better.
I'm not playing.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna make some calls.